la esta edificación del cáncer de pulmón
se refiere a la extensión de la
enfermedad si usted tiene la forma más
común de cáncer de pulmón o cáncer de
pulmón de células no pequeñas este se
está edificará según el tamaño del tumor
y si se ha extendido a los ganglios
linfáticos u otros órganos del cuerpo en
el estadio oculto o escondido las
células cancerígenas se encuentran en la
mucosidad que se tose o en otros fluidos
pulmonares pero no se detecta ningún
tumor en los pulmones el estadio 0 no se
considera invasivo porque las células
cancerígenas se encuentran en el
revestimiento más interno de los
conductos de aire pero no han crecido a
través de ellos el estadio 1a
se considera cáncer invasivo porque el
tumor ha crecido a través del
revestimiento interior de las vías
respiratorias hasta el tejido profundo
de los pulmones cuando se mide el tumor
no tiene más de tres centímetros de
diámetro y no se ha extendido a los
bronquios ganglios linfáticos o puntos
distantes en el estadio uno ve el
diámetro del tumor es superior a tres
centímetros o éste se ha extendido a un
bronquio principal o ha crecido a través
del
hasta la capa interna de la pleura en el
estadio 2a el tumor no mide más de 3
centímetros de ancho pero se ha
extendido hagan los linfáticos cercanos
en el mismo lado del pecho que el tumor
se pueden presentar dos escenarios con
el cáncer de pulmón de estadio 2 b 1
donde las células cancerígenas no se han
extendido a los ganglios linfáticos
cercanos pero han invadido la pared
torácica el diafragma la pleura las
membranas que rodean el corazón o un
bronquio principal en el segundo
escenario para el estadio 2 ve el cáncer
se ha extendido a los ganglios
linfáticos en el mismo lado del pecho
que el tumor
además el tumor tiene más de 3
centímetros de ancho ha crecido en un
bronquio principal o ha crecido por el
pulmón hasta la pleura en el estadio 3 y
el tumor puede tener cualquier tamaño y
las células cancerígenas se han
extendido hasta los ganglios linfáticos
en el mismo lado que el tumor pulmonar
además el cáncer puede haberse extendido
a la pared torácica el diafragma la
pleura las membranas que rodean el
corazón o un bronquio principal
pero no a la tráquea en el estadio 3 ve
el tumor puede tener cualquier tamaño y
se ha extendido a los ganglios
linfáticos ubicados sobre la clavícula o
en el otro lado del pecho el cáncer
puede haberse extendido a estructuras
cercanas como el corazón los vasos
principales del corazón el diafragma la
pared torácica la tráquea el esófago el
esternón o a más de un lugar del mismo
pulmón en el estadio cuadro el cáncer se
ha extendido a otros lóbulos del mismo
pulmón o al otro pulmón y se ha
extendido a otras partes del cuerpo como
el cerebro el hígado los riñones las
glándulas suprarrenales o los huesos